from 68 teams down to the final two
baylor
and gonzaga meet for the ncaa title
tonight sports director chris matthews
live in studio with a preview chris
i'll tell you what brothers can be a lot
of fun basketball fans from fresno to
flushing are gearing up
for tonight's big game this is only the
second time in ncaa basketball history
the two teams
ranked in the top three over the entire
course of the regular season
will meet for the title both teams won
their final four match up very different
ways
baylor blew out houston boy the bears
just mauled the cougars
but that gonzaga ucla game it was
one for the ages there might not be a
better game
in the history of final fours or even
the tournament for that matter
but that is now a memory only relived in
tonight's one shining moment because
tonight
it's go time with the bulldogs looking
to become the first unbeaten team
since 1976. i know coach few and i we
we we joked when the game got cancelled
then we went to
uh the arena and we did a a press
conference saying that the game was
cancelled and
whatnot and as we were riding back we're
like uh well you know what if we end up
playing this game in the
in the final four the championship game
um that that that sounds like a better
idea so
that that was obviously the goal for
both of us
all right now we'll see if the bulldogs
have another bite left because
boy it's going to be hard to top what
happened on saturday night
join us following the game we'll have
complete highlights for you kevin martin
will have reaction from a sports book
and of course the biggest golden knights
are playing but another busy night
enjoy the game here is my prediction
gonzaga 74
baylor 68 brian what do you think about
that one i'm gonna go whoever has the
ball last
and i think so i'm gonna go gonzaga by
one point by the way that was locked on
channel eight saturday night that game
gonzaga ucla
as you pointed out maybe one of the best
in history that was
riveting your heart breaks from the
bruins really too yeah and you were
saying you didn't miss
one single play of that game you were
watching it your eyes were glued i was
stapled to the couch yes it was amazing
yeah we'll see what happens tonight
74-68 what's your prediction i'll go
77-76
denise uh i'll go 78-76
sure why not i hate ted's going for
gonzaga too so we'll see what happens
tonight at nine o'clock all right